[Music]
[Music]
if anything goes wrong I'll turn us
around in a heartbeat I know you oh
whoops I like how everyone loves
Quicksilver and in this movie he
practically does nothing he's reduced to
a professional seatbelt unbuckle and a
professional taper he's one of the most
powerful x-men and he literally gets
heated out of the movie with ourselves
Charles mr. president are you seeing
this on TV okay hold on a second and the
last movie Charles delivers a message
that basically threatens the entire
world but I have returned the day of
reckoning is here and now he has a
personal line to the president what also
in Days of Future past magneto was going
to kill the president and it was
recorded live so how did the x-men have
fans they've literally been threatening
the earth countless times even with
mystique this little girl loves her and
they're selling action figures
apparently but she tried to assassinate
like some world leaders and she pointed
a gun at a room of like high executives
in the White House after having a little
skirmish in the neighborhood flipping
two cars
and destroying the propellers on a
helicopter the government is now cutting
ties of the x-men and setting up
interment camps as Xavier I think you
talked to the president they didn't even
do this when the world was almost
destroyed eventually cities urban
centers anything built since the bronze
age will be went away
hey but a couple cars get flipped and
part of a helicopter he gets destroyed
as screwed dude lock him up right now
it's also funny how they have this
basketball court right above their
hangar you're telling me that anytime
they want to leave they kids have to
clear out and stop their game they have
this entire estate and yet they choose
the basketball court like put it
anywhere else there's literally a big
clearing right here and by the way the
women are always saving the men around
here you might want to think about
changing the name to ex women oh that
was both very cringy and it doesn't make
sense
the women save all the men what about
last movie were Quicksilver saves
everyone in the mansion
[Music]
so two mutants are basically tearing
this helicopter in half wouldn't it be a
bright idea to have everyone get in it
so these aliens have the power to like
move matter or something and it's like
insta-kill people but at the end of the
movie they just resort to fist fighting
why I think makes perfect sense so it
makes sense because it doesn't make
sense in fact that you're railing about
it doesn't make a lot of sense for this
part I need to talk about a few plot
points in the movie gene accidentally
kills Raven and Hank basically loses it
and blames everything on Charles which
isn't of itself really stupid we've been
trying to protect these kids from the
world when really we should have been
protecting them from you Jean ghosts
Magneto's camp for shelter and basically
just asked him about vengeance because
she's mad at her father for leaving her
when she was young
magneto says I've lived with vengeance
my whole life killed whatever I thought
like pain go away didn't so it's very
clear that he denounces vengeance then
literally ten minutes later this happens
when Hank shows up static Jane killed
her if I find her I'll kill her so
you're telling me that after going
through a two minute monologue about
vengeance being bad you immediately do a
180 understand so after Raven getting
killed
does magneto even like Raven in this
timeline it wasn't like he was trying to
kill her in Days of Future past
towards the end the Dark Phoenix before
like the big action set piece in the
Train Charles tries to convince Hank and
Magneto to not kill Jean before the
aliens show up and this is me Jean we
can still save her she's still Jean
inside what a compelling argument Hank
and Magneto were so hell-bent on killing
Jean for the last half of the movie and
then flip because of Charles's sorry
attempt at being persuasive amazing
writing it's got to be the best writer
I've ever seen so it would seem storm is
obviously very powerful and for most of
the movie she just shoots lightning from
her hands and actually shoots ice cubes
at someone it's not till the end of the
movie where she actually uses her powers
Mike used to be a fan so this is the
only interaction that Nightcrawler has
with this guy later on one of the aliens
kills him and Knight collar just goes
crazy over his death for some reason
throughout the whole movie he showed no
signs of being bad but he snaps when
someone dies who he doesn't know at all
look at him he's literally crazy now all
right guys this is the most illogical
point in the whole movie how the hell
does this alien know how to walk in high
heels let alone run in them oh god I'm
getting Jurassic world flashbacks
alright so we're finally at the end of
the movie and I have no idea what the
hell is happening it's basically just a
light show at this point let me crank up
the brightness I think it'll help you
guys understand what's happening right
now my emotions make me strong hey give
it up give it up the Simon Kinberg what
amazing writing he deserves an Oscar for
the screenplay you guys are gonna mess
up my jet ski hold up